students at the Soweto School for the
Deaf say it's a sanctuary sign language
is commonly used and they say they're
easily understood and feel included
now that signing has been recognized as
an official language in South Africa
it's hoped that more than 200 students
here as well as the broader deaf
Community will benefit the government
says it's to promote inclusivity and
protect the rights of people who are
deaf and hard of hearing they are so
happy you will hear for yourselves they
are so happy because they will tell you
that if the government can
introduce sign language as a subject
even in the mainstream not only or in
the deaf schools also in in the
mainstream they need to learn sign
language so that they can learn sign
language
it can become easy for them to
communicate
there are more than four million deaf
people in South Africa but only about 40
schools cater for the deaf while the new
law means that government departments
and services will have to make
Provisions for those wanting to use sign
language there are a number of
challenges one we have very scarce
interpreters we have very low number of
sign language professional sign language
and temperatures in this country too the
education system in the deaf school is
still needs a lot of work so we we still
have to empower and for deaf people who
can go to University study and activists
say far more work is needed to remove
social barriers South Africa's
recognition of sign language is a
milestone supporters say it's an
acknowledgment of the culture and
identity of the deaf Community
especially on a continent where only
three other countries have done the same
family Al Jazeera Johannesburg
make sure to subscribe to our channel to
get the latest news from Al Jazeera